I do love talking science with you
because I don't know jack they're still
curious and you preserve that into
adulthood I actually this is even ready
it but I bought your book last week on
Amazon I haven't been able to read it
yet not because you're coming on I
actually didn't even know that then I
just love you it's so cool
so tell me about science okay sorry it's
so scientists okay our kids who never
grew up
oh that's what artists are yeah yeah
what are kids that you Turney what's
under here and what's it you know and
they're taking things apart they're
basically experimenting and it's parents
we tend to over constrain their
experiments it's been the first year
their lives
teaching them to walk and talk and the
rest of their lives tell them to shut up
and sit down
yeah am i right but I need you to
explain a few things like sonic boom go
love me some sonic okay I love sonic so
when you sing when any of us makes any
sound the sound emanates at the speed of
sound from you okay now suppose you
start moving well the sound that's in
front of you is not leaving you as fast
as the sound behind you and there's a
point where you move so fast well I
didn't gotten that part yet
you went so fast that the sound that you
make does not advance in front of you at
all what because you're going the speed
of sound itself I'll see you around and
you go faster than it all your sound
goes behind you and all that sound
gathers up on a shock wave and that's
shockwave if it's an airplane is moving
through the air and by the time it hits
the ground in a BAM because then the
sound that it generated the sonic booms
in our lives
at the crack of a whip that's a sonic
boom at the tip of the whip the tip of
the whip okay musical
black holes
okay no I didn't learn no cuz I feel
like it was wasted on me as a kid here
you're gonna feel like it's over your
head and now I'm an adult Lemmons
everyone avoid them avoid them you will
not ever come out to tell us what was
there but where will you go well okay I
would totally go I will tell you as you
get near a black hole the difference in
gravity between your head and your feet
begins to grow which means your feet
will fall towards the black hole faster
than your head will will I get taller
yes yes the getting taller part will
never cease and so it'll continue the
whole tidal forces and your body will be
stretched to the point where the tidal
forces exceed the intermolecular forces
that hold your flesh together and so
then your body will snap in two likely
at the base of your waist at the base of
your spine then you those two parts and
then those two parts feel the forces and
they split into two pieces and then four
and then eight and you will bifurcate
all the way down to this cosmic of this
word of the day by fabric of space and
time narrows it funnels down to a point
so you have a certain width up here and
you get extruded out like a fabric of
space like toothpaste through a tube so
if you die in that way we have a word
for that it's called spaghettification
is that a real word yes it is a real you
look it up I composed a poem about black
holes but just to summarize what you
just learned
I bet it's
right yeah in this feat first dive to
this cosmic abyss you will not survive
because you will not miss the tidal
forces of gravity will create quite a
calamity when you're stretched head to
toe are you sure you want to go
your body's atoms you'll see them will
enter one by one the event horizon will
eat them and you won't be having fun I
wanted to ask you I think what's the
scary thing about the universe it's not
falling into a black hole no no this way
scarier stuff than that in five billion
years the Sun will become bloated it
will expand soul are all right the Sun
in five billion years okay bloat to
become so large it will engulf the
entire orbits of Mercury and Venus
surface will be so near to earth the
earth's temperature will rise
exponentially and the oceans will come
to a rolling boil as they evaporate into
the atmosphere then the atmosphere will
evaporate into space and we will be this
charred ember as we get absorbed by the
Sun descending into the crucible that is
it's burning Center there's no segue
here I just want to you know kind of
Gerrits way from terrifying okay so when
I did your show a couple years ago we
talked about the great American and
cliffs yeah which I actually saw in my
farm I was so jealous cuz I took I fed
all this money to go to a mountaintop
and I could have just been invited to
your backyard is my invitation still in
my rock
the invitation no honestly was the last
thing I and all the animals everything
started making noise the crickets
everything started meeting they thought
it was nighttime and the craziest
behaving animals are the humans we were
pretty nice but we were drinking too but
wait I want to leave everyone with a
little hope ok cuz we've got a little
zero dark thirty and I'm scared to walk
into my house now umm and I never want
to go near a black hole so just maybe
give us something helpful from the
universe derived from a cosmic beautiful
that's why makes us smile the atoms of
your body are traceable to events that
have long ago occurred in the universe
especially stars that have manufactured
these elements and exploded scattering
that enrichment across the galaxy
enabling planets to form and life upon
them so when you stand out side and look
up at the night sky it's not we're here
and the stars are there we are a
participant in this great unfolding
cosmic journey and it is and it is not
just figuratively true it is literally
true that we are Stardust so ours is it
is not it is not that we are in the
universe that's true but what's even
more true is that the universe is in
[Applause]
the universe within me I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this